this is double angle identity we have
double I think angle identities for sine
it costs as well what I want you to
notice about it is is that if you have a
double angle identity you can just
easily rewrite this as a half angle
identity good I mean you think our
libguides are half this value over here
so instead of going from here and
they're doubling I'm here from here
and then half just going the other
direction confuse one of me let's just
suppose I have can't be on the left hand
side so I have this angle over here
so therefore I should have all these
angles over here it's still a [ __ ] in a
bit like energy so here's what I'm going
to write 210 1/2 theta or fit onto
that's on the top what's on the bottom
one minus 10 squared 0 2 okay so we call
this guy about half angle identity for 2
it's the double angle if you just
dressed up in slightly different clothes
now this looks weird why would this open
doors why would it be useful we've seen
the way that these can you see okay what
we do is we say actually if you can work
with this this actually unlocks the link
between trigonometry and algebra that's
really useful because you go ahead of a
lot about algebra you're really good at
algebra we spent years developing that
if we can hijack some of your knowledge
and skill with that with trig that's
kind of cool so we say less we introduce
a new pretty rule since we're dealing
with tan which is the letter T now we
say let's let T equal this we'd walk
with half angles in hand of feet up on
to okay so if you introduce this I'm
gonna rewrite this first line
therefore tan si R equals 2/5 on 1 minus
T Square period so you can see what I've
done is I've dressed up the
trigonometric identity and algebra now
what's even cooler at this is that if
this is true if I understand
substitutions we label in this is true
it implies that there's some writing
triangle somewhere out there existence
where opposite on adjacent natural pain
is is checking on one minus T Square
opposite on a Jason let's draw a
triangle so underneath me if you try
yourself page right angle triangle type
zone this would be only in the quantity
if Candida is 2 T on 1 minus T squared
there here's the other side over here to
T and here is the adjacent side 1
multi-screen
that's a right angle triangle so
therefore I can use Pythagoras to work
out what the missing side is let's just
call it um if the hypothesis is called H
and now H squared going to be equal to
what so there's one of the signs Square
and the other side squared right
ok let's watch with this a little bit
the top ring on it - tea or squared
becomes 40 square don't forget you're
spreading both terms over here ok we're
going to get some because that decane we
can deal with that is going to be 1
minus 2 Z square plus 2 the form okay I
can collect some like terms I can let's
see I can click these guys here so that
leaves me with 1 plus 2t split that's
how many T squared I have and that T is
the power of 4 just hangs up
then the right hand side now I know you
don't work with her powers for very
often that's a quarter photo as we call
it but hopefully if you think about this
and how it compares to say this part of
the previous slide
do you recognize that what you're
looking at right now is another perfect
square
what is it the square off yeah this is
one plus t-squared
squared is it not like if the only
difference with this guy and this guy is
that murder two T squared plus 2t
squared well that would work if I just
change the saloon okay what's is hoping
what am i doing what am i solving I'll
try to find the hypotenuse right rows
behind parties squared is that squared
then the hypotenuse is just the thing
inside the bracket one plus t-squared do
you agree okay so you can see how I just
sort of relabeled things I said well if
you're real able I guess you've got a
new triangle
what makes triangle let's see what
happens with my favors this is what I
got now
so can't eat it is that now I can say
what side did it and Cosby right because
now I know all the sides of the Train
right
I'd say I'm going to do it here sine
theta is opposite on hypotenuse you're
not which in this triangle is 2t over 1
plus T sweat and likewise closely enough
it is or conversely acetate is adjacent
on hypotenuse so that's going to be 1
minus T squared we already identified
validation sign on 1 plus T squared ok
so what we've now done this is stare and
you can put a nice big box around this
we have a new way to reframe all of the
trigonometric functions you can deal
with all of them sighs 110 without ever
talking about sine qua detail you guys
deal with them in algebraic objects ok
these results because they all vary in
terms of this
we finger call we call them the tea
results okay there are also often cause
for this exactly isn't up here the half
angle results because that's what the
teas stand for can of half your eggs
okay so sometimes I'll put something
sometimes are particularly older
texting's
will often call their couple years old
but they've harmony will resolve or
something like that
so how is this useful to us I will show
you two ways in this lesson and we can
get style number and you'll you start to
again appreciation for why it looks a
bit messages that way it's hard to learn
I should point out the reference sheet
has a lot of inter so he ever like oh my
goodness my brain is just treat a lot of
people just overload their brain review
stuff fittings I'm gonna write the
repetition is trying to tell you don't
worry about different worry about what
is easy which is already busy right now